MTF agents scramble through the crowd of
bloodthirsty hypnotized Festival goers
up on the stage a pair of living statues
hold down a screaming man as they
produce medieval instruments of torture
from an antique case maybe this time the
agents can stop it maybe they can
prevent all the horror and bloodshed but
one thing stands in their way a
man-sized cartoonish dove costume flying
down towards them wielding a large
wooden Mallet that would only bring
death and destruction needless to say
even by Foundation standards this one is
going to be weird when you found
yourself sought out by the SCP
foundation's recruitment Division and
offered a role in the research
department they made sure to inform you
of the risks after all a workplace
injury in this line of work might be far
more serious than slipping on a wet
floor or developing carpal tunnel from
typing all day working within the ranks
of the foundation you could be the
fortunate victim of any number of
dangerous anomalies whether it's scp-096
appearing behind you after you
accidentally caught a glimpse of it as a
single Pixel in a photo or if you were
in the wrong place at the wrong time
whenever scp-682 next broke out then
chances are you'd be receiving an early
redundancy and a closed casket service
if there's even enough of you left to
bury it is the one thing you never want
to happen the scenario you're constantly
warned about from the moment you join
the foundation a Containment Breach
anything can be the cause of an anomaly
Breaking Free of containment and
spreading Untold chaos in the process
whether it's the result of a
particularly cantankerous SCP that
doesn't take kindly to being locked up
an act of earnest human error with
disastrous consequences or even
International sabotage enacted by a
group of interests trying to seize
anomalies for their own purposes there
is no telling when or where a can
Containment Breach might occur or is
there despite all the resources at their
disposal specialized facilities spanning
the globe advanced technology and a
nearly inexhaustible supply of personnel
to contain as CPS the foundation still
manages to suffer catastrophic
casualties as a result of containment
breaches but surely if they're so well
equipped such breaches should be almost
impossible right well yes so what causes
them what if every Containment Breach
all the loss of life the further spread
of anomalies and the destruction of
foundation property incurred was all
caused by an SCP not a living entity
mind you more some kind of latent
anomalous phenomenon that triggers
containment breaches without warning the
prevailing theories surrounding this
phenomenon is even itself considered to
be an SCP within its own right referred
to as
scp-001 of course as many of those
well-versed in the history and practices
of the SCP Foundation will already know
scp-001 is a designation shared by a
number of anomalies some are believed to
actually exist While others are
speculated to just be falsified covers
created to mask the real
scp-001 from beings such as the gate
guardian and the Scarlet King to the
existence of God's blind spot and even
the foundation itself each of these
scp-001s are nicknamed after the
foundation researcher who proposed them
for the designation and often considered
to be some of the first if not the very
first anomalies ever encountered or at
least documented in that regard this
scp-001 plague's proposal could well be
one of the very first latent anomalies
to exist explaining why so many scps
were uncontained prior to the foundation
being established and why even now with
all their resources containment breaches
are still a worryingly frequent
occurrence there are multiple anomalies
that appear to have been directly
affected by scp-001 at least according
to the research of one of the
foundation's directors director leg
while he might be drawn conclusions and
seeing patterns where there aren't any
to speak of leg reasons that these
circumstances of these specific recorded
containment breaches seem to indicate
that scp-001 was at fault the first of
these incidences director Lake focuses
on and his research is also the one
we'll be focusing on for the remainder
of this video it is designated as
scp-001-1
scp-001-1 previously went under the
designation of
scp-5770 it is an annual anomalous event
that occurs in the Piazza de la signora
in Florence Italy the event consists of
an unscheduled Festival that goes on for
a period of 10 days wherein anyone
present within a 10 kilometer range of
the affected area suffers a
mind-altering effect that compels them
to attend the festival however SCP
001-1 is not a well-documented
long-running festival of great cultural
significance to the people of Florence
neither is it an event that is widely
advertised yet those who have
experienced the psychic draw of this
anomalous Festival are driven to
attendance during the course of
scp-001-1 two anomalous entities that
resemble the statues created by
Michelangelo during the Renaissance will
host a show where they take to the stage
to judge people they deem to be Sinners
this pair of statue creatures will call
upon the audience and bring those
they've designated Sinners up onto the
stage with them and will then enact
makes makeshift grueling punishments
these have been noted to resemble the
acts depicted in Dante allegeris Inferno
so if you ever need any further proof of
how hellish these punishments are we
recommend asking an Art Expert the
moment that scp-001-1 ceases and the
festival comes to a close any and all in
attendance are subject to yet another
form of anomalous mental alteration and
will seed to instantly forget the event
any of the horrific tortures performed
on stage becomes unknown to those that
directly witnessed it leaving them
unaware of anything that occurred only
moments prior so given the foundation's
extensive knowledge of this Festival its
gruesome proceedings and the effects it
has on those in attendance you might be
forgiven for expecting them to have a
fairly well established method of
keeping the event contained presumably
setting up a cordon to keep attendance
out of the area administering amnestics
to any that might have been affected by
scp-001-1's anomalous mind-altering but
then you remember
scp-001 the theory behind what could be
the cause of containment breaches as a
result the foundation has still been
unable to establish containment of the
event formerly known as
scp-5770 and director legs research has
tied this issue with containment to
scp-001 hence the festival's
redesignation to
scp-001-1 following the initial
discovery of an anomalous annual
occurrence in the City of Florence in
1985. the SCP foundation's head
researcher assigned to what was then
known as
scp-5770 was one Joseph Pasqua former
site director at site 322. Pasquale was
according to the incidents recorded on
the foundation's own database somehow
manipulated by one of the anomalous
statue creatures that performed the show
during occurrences of
scp-5770 it was thanks to the influence
of this entity that Joseph Pasqua
deserted his post at the foundation and
went into hiding the fact that the
influence of one of the performers of
this Festival was able to extend its
influence to a senior member of the
foundation was not only troubling but
also constituted a Containment Breach
pasquote would later be tracked down by
Foundation agents operating in and
around Italy it was discovered 30 years
later after his desertion in Vatican
City as a member of the palpal conclave
a specially selected group of Catholic
Cardinals that are charged with electing
a new pope if the former site director
was still being influenced by the statue
creatures it is highly likely that he
spent the previous three decades
climbing the ranks of the Catholic
Church potentially to install a new pope
at the behest of the entities
responsible for conducting the torture
of the Florence Festival another
recorded incident of a Containment
Breach surrounding the event that seemed
to lend Credence to the existence of
scp-001 the anomalous cause of breaches
occurred the year following as CP 5770's
Discovery in 1986 the foundation was
observing the proceedings of the
festival as part of their ongoing
investigation into its bizarre nature
on-site were agents of mobile task force
Zeta 66 better known under their unit's
code name of the Guardian Angels during
the festival MTF Zeta 66 operatives
noticed the presence of a previously
unknown entity associated with the
anomalous event the foundation was
already aware of the pair of seemingly
living Michelangelo sculptures
designating them as
scp-5770-1 and
scp-5770-2 respectively this third
entity despite being given the
designation of
scp-5770-3 had its own preferred
identification for itself the being
referred to itself as God's strongest
Soldier and resembled a mascot costume
of a dove approximately two meters tall
this creature's body was entirely Hollow
there was nothing within the costume the
costume was its body the responding
agent of MTF Zeta 66 codenamed Zeta
turquoise was the first to confront
God's strongest Soldier and was greeted
with quite the opener
God's strongest Soldiers by name getting
rid of sin is my game confused at the
creature's demeanor and presence Zeta
turquoise called in a report to command
stating that a large Birdman was
harassing random attendance of the
festival when turquoise moved in to
confront scp-57 170-3 the creature
repeated its assertion that it was God's
strongest Soldier and that its aim was
to get people into heaven the agent
requested that God's strongest Soldier
get out of his way he had a job to do
but the bizarre Birdman responded with
more Whimsical nonsense burger sandwich
fruit and Fries you just told a big fan
lie God's strongest Soldier proclaimed
Twilight
upon Zeta turquoise's attempt to push
past the creature
scp-5770-3 produced an oversized wooden
Mallet seemingly from out of thin air it
then wound its arms back and immediately
viciously struck the MTF agent a low
orbit Foundation satellite reported not
long after that an object had been
detected exiting the Earth's
stratosphere analysis confirmed that it
was indeed Zeta turquoise yes he was
literally heated into Earth's orbit by a
cartoonishly large wooden Mallet as for
the entity known as God's strongest
Soldier the bird-like creature then
proceeded to attack the other members of
mobile task force Zeta 66 in a similar
fashion making sure they got to heaven
in every sense of the phrase with
multiple recorded instances of
containment breaches occurring in
relation to the festival in Florence and
happening so frequently more and more
evidence of director legg's theory about
scp-0 001 was being validated in 1988
the foundation attempted a different
more pacifistic approach to containing
the annual Celebration by attempting to
cordon off the entrance to the area of
Florence where those compelled to attend
the festival usually congregated there
was additionally a cover story issued to
the public stating that this was done as
a quarantine measure to keep residents
away from an area hosting a potentially
dangerous infection for a time this
seemed to be working the streets were
quiet local residents seemed to be going
about their business and paying little
mind to the foundation operatives in the
area that is until the mind-altering
effects of scp-001-1 took hold a mass of
people estimated to be over one hundred
thousand florentines charged towards the
cordon off area this mass of people
swept through like a tidal wave breaking
through a dam causing Foundation
Personnel to be trampled alive those
that survived the initial Rush were
attacked by civilians in what seemed to
be a coordinated effort to reach the
Gatherings area for the festival all
Foundation agents in the area were
terminated in short order mercilessly
slaughtered and then cannibalized before
anything that remained of their bodies
was dumped into the Arno River nearby as
well as being evidence of the sheer
mental alteration the statue creatures
and the festival itself were capable of
for director Lake this seemed to
indicate something further if an anomaly
scp-001 was truly responsible for all
containment breaches allowing them to
occur in spite of the measures taken to
prevent such things happening then the
phenomenon seemed to be occurring
specifically to prevent the foundation
from achieving containment of certain
scps legs theory developed with every
passing breach that involved
scp-001-1 in theory the festival should
be an average Tuesday for foundation
staff a relative walk in the park in
order to contain it if not outright stop
it from happening at all yet despite all
their resources Manpower and expertise
in all things anomalous the Fem
Foundation had been thwarted at every
turn despite how illogical such
occurrences seemed containment breaches
were still occurring at an alarming rate
and perhaps none more so than in
relation to scp-001 the following year
1989 brought with it the most
inexplicable breach yet and further
proof for director Lake's theory about
scp-001 while the previous breaches were
undoubtedly anomalous in nature each
always carrying with the possibility
that somehow despite the low odds the
foundation missed something some human
error or previously undiscovered
information about the festival could
have led to pasqua's alteration or the
arrival of God's strongest Soldier but
this time it was undeniably that a force
beyond the scope of the foundation's
understanding was altering reality to
prevent them from containing the
festival in Florence an invisible
barrier manifested at every entry point
to the main area of the anomalous event
whenever a member of foundation
Personnel tried to get in on foot those
that attempted to access the festival
area via rappelling out of helicopters
instantly caught a blaze and burned to
death the moment they touched down on
the ground any helicopter transports
also crashed on their return journey to
site 322 and God's strongest Soldier was
seen trampling on the wreckage before
flapping its arms and flying away it was
following this incident that leg was
promoted to position of site director
for site 322 as a replacement for Joseph
Pasqua who was still missing at this
time the newly appointed director was
yet to devise his theory that there
existed an anomalous cause for all
containment breaches however during his
introductory briefing he was presented
with the file regarding
scp-5770 and the various examples of it
not only being uncontainable but being
very good at not being contained
director Legg asked if some of the more
standard methods had been attempted at
this point the foundation had tried
aerial bombardments at the festival
Scranton reality anchors to counteract
whatever anomalous force was preventing
can containment even using scp-682 to
clear the area it had all failed
figuring out why was now director leg's
job all the information of previously
failed attempts to contain the festival
LED leg to the conclusion that scp-001
must exist an unseen phenomenon the
missing piece of the puzzle the element
specifically interfering with the
foundation's efforts he presented his
proposal to the overseer Council who
were skeptical to say the least they
posited that the statues and bird mascot
creature might be smarter than the
latter's outwardly cartoonish nature
portrayed but this is exactly what to
director leg indicated as cp001 was
responsible he explained that all in
attendance at
scp-5770s Festival took the event
seriously but the appearance of God's
strongest Soldier was in abnormality
whose demeanor and tone were drastically
different from the rest of the rather
Cutthroat proceedings director Legg
explained that the sheer absurdity of
creatures seem to be the result of
scp-001 interfering with their
operations after all if some other cause
was to blame like an unknown cult
attacking Foundation Personnel when they
attempted to contain the festival then
there would be evidence of that and leg
would have no reason to suspect that
God's strongest Soldier was anything
more than just a tonally dissonant part
of the Festival of course director leg
couldn't prove the existence of scp-001
based on the presence of one cartoonish
bird mascot at a festival but before
long more and more breaches would start
occurring that seemed to further prove
that leg was on to something there was
something else at work causing
containment breaches that put the
entirety of the foundation in Jeopardy
now go check out scp-001 when day breaks
and scp-001 which is the real zero zero
one for more